servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video leute ich bin heute hier mit
leuten was richtig krass es ist passiert
und zwar jetzt electronic arts auf uns
zugekommen auf luca und mädchen hat
gesagt jungs habt ihr nicht auf eine
kooperation wir beide zocken mega viel
tiefer so in unserer freizeit aber es
ist gedacht ja klar das machen klar
diese ganze sache funktioniert so leute
am anfang wenn wir uns beide ein team
zusammenstellt mainz wird im heutigen
video das ihr gerade sehr
zusammengestellt lukas
teamzusammenstellung videos auch gerade
untergegangen dazu ist der linken in der
beschreibung danach werden wir mit den
teams gegeneinander antreten ein spieler
auf meinem kanal ein spiel auf kanal von
typen kennen habe seinen kanal alles
klar
holen wir von heute an mit der
zusammenstellung wir ziehen jetzt für
sie bei ultimate team tags und in den
parks sind verschiedene spieler wird das
ist so ähnlich wie bei eine ahnung
irgendwelchen sammelkarten oder so
früher und man versucht sich dann quasi
das beste raus blick und dadurch ein
rassist ihm zu machen es wird allerdings
keine ahnung hat von tiefer in allen
guten geistern verlassen leute ein paar
von euch bestimmt auch schon fifa für
alle die es nicht wissen tiefer ist eine
fußball simulator ach ja ich das spiel
hockey genau fifa ist ein fußball
simulator und da gibt es eben einen
modus der heißt alte mit ihm da kann man
sich sein perfektes team ein eigenes
team zusammenstellen das habe ich bei
fifa 17 und einigen davor auch schon
ultra gesucht und was wir bekommen haben
wir haben so gestört viele fifa points
bekommen so in gmbh und quasi mit dem
man diese packs kaufen kann und wir
rasten heute einfach aufgrund ihren
schreien wie affen oder trauen
man muss halt auch dazu sagen dass es
gerade so stream spieler gibt also jetzt
gerade wenn wir das wieder aufnimmt ist
es ist doch gar nicht halloween aber es
gibt gerade krasse updates für spieler
krasse verbesserung und die gibt es
teilweise im text das seht ihr auch
direkt die sind dann so hofft er wird
jetzt gerade eingeblendet da unten und
es kann sein dass sie welche davon heute
ziehen wäre das kann doch nicht sein und
wir müssen halt bei dem teambuilding
auch darauf aufpassen dass die spieler
eine gewisse chemie haben und halt dass
man kann zum beispiel nicht irgendwie
ronaldo und messi nehmen weil das ist
ein portugiese und nagetiere muss auch
alles abgeben und liegen jetzt das
ausrasten
früher hat man für sie ist münster und
kräuter indem man diese packs kaufen
können wir die spieler drin sind hat man
so gehasst
30 spiele gemacht wird da haben wir
wieder ein staat bereit
ich versuche was bleibt wenn jetzt von
ihm so kräftige points bekommen also
gestört wir können uns unser ganzes
leben kaufen das ist so als ob das ist
so als hätte man sein ganzes leben lang
für einen euro pro stunde gearbeitet und
dann kommt deutsche band gesellschaft
und sagt jetzt 30 millionen kaufte ihr
autos videos das ja so dass jetzt gerade
der lifestyle das gelingt es gibt so
browserspiele okay wir sind so lala die
sind die steuern gibt selber spieler die
sind schon ein bisschen besser dann gibt
es gold spieler diese den sets hier und
wir holen uns einfach die krassesten
sets ist gerade die seltenen goldschätze
davon darf man sogar fünf kaufen das er
verkaufen oder für 64.000
ein erster teil in sweet spieler und
leute was am anfang gezeigt wird ist der
beste spieler aus dem ganzen pack und es
ist einfach nicht rasiert alter leute
ist wird so witzig manche tücke so geil
und den ganzen rest dessen zur
verbrauchs objekte also spielerverträge
und so das kann man gebrauchen diese
jetzt halt pro spiel verliert jeder
spieler ein vertragspunkte und er hat
dann beispielsweise sieben vertrags
punkten aus sieben spielen was von der
neuen vertrag kaufen mussten uns halt
nicht mehr darüber informieren damit wir
euch das spiel näher legen sondern also
ich zocke fifa seit zwölf jahren jung
ich auch alter leute wild hog ich habe
angefangen mit fifa ich glaube fifa 04
es war der game boy advance sp dann kurz
zuvor getroffenen klo spiel mit ohne
witz lottogeschichte wir haben bei
meiner großtante zu besuchende
geburtstag hat man gern bei der frage
hallo gesagt bin straight aufs klo
marschiert und habe so lange fifa
gezockt bis sie mich da herausgeholt
haben kein scheiß
das kollegin ziehen wird
die glück als sven quandt als irgendein
krassen komm schon
der ist aber dass gut lange nicht
ausreichend da konnte man sich weil ich
versuchen da ich mir so ein bundesliga
team aufzubauen nächstes tag wehrmacht
auf die lampe klarer fall es gibt diese
seltenen halloween spielerhosen 1 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
irgendwie
[Musik]
dänemark das die 80 stabiler dänemark
oder norwegen aber dicker und stabiler
der kommen auf jeden fall mein verein
die da wie der ist auch ganz gut da
kommt man 3 1 bundesliga richtig viele
leute
leute was sie gesehen hat war vor
ungefähr eineinhalb wochen in der zeit
hat mich aber immer noch weiter packs
gezogen und weiter meine mannschaft
verbessert dabei ist unter anderem das
hier passiert
[Musik]
leute über stick ich bin grad beim
feiern und haptik aufgemacht opec
aufgewacht war in alter 500.000 ich
dachte mir so jo ok scheiß drauf ist 82
passieren manchmal pack auf 1 4001
vollkommen gestört halter was wird auf
jeden fall habe ich mega telemann team
investiert leute jetzt zeige ich euch
mein team mit dem ich gegen luca
antreten werde komplett also geht
einfach da kommen wir uns in meinem team
leute es ist wie gesagt ein bundesliga
tief und einige von den spielern werden
wir auf jeden fall kennen denn das team
ist in meinen augen relativ gut relativ
krass geworden fangen wir haben mit dem
turbo auf der torwart position haben wir
niemand geringeren als manuel neuer
leute glaubt das ist der beste im ganzen
spiel damit perfekt für unsere
bundesligamannschaft als linken
verteidiger haben wie jerome boateng
leute 88er bewertung richtig kasse in
fatal definitiv einer der besten
innenverteidiger der bundesliga und
vitalia neben boateng als verstärkung
für die innenverteidigung haben wir
sokratis von borussia dortmund 86 der
sogar noch schneller als boateng
richtige maschinen ich habe mit dem
schon ein bisschen gespielt der rasiert
auf jeden fall und auf der position des
rechten außenverteidigers haben wir
mitchell weiser von hertha bsc
herrschaftlichen vereinte die ich
persönlich sehr mag weil sie hat jetzt
nicht so mega viele punkte ist aber
schnell und ist aus dem spiel heraus
richtig starken linksaußen als
linksverteidiger haben wir ein richtiges
und zwar damit aller war richtig richtig
guter spieler mega stark auch offensiv
voll gut eine legende allerspätestens
seit diesem sommer
wer mich alle berge
und wir machen weiter mit im zentralen
defensiven mittelfeld da haben wir
arturo vidal l vom fc bayern münchen
auch eine richtige maschine 780 echt
schon krass viele punkte linkes
mittelfeld haben wir niemand geringeren
als marco reus von borussia dortmund
richtige maschine der kann schiessen der
kann rennen der kalender kann penn
demgegenüber auf der rechten seite haben
wenn niemand geringeren als arjen robben
maschine alter 88 einer der krassesten
dribbler im spiel die ich bisher
überhaupt gespielt habe geht ultra hab
aber halt nur einen fuß ist längst fuß
und mit rechts geht bei dem gar nix ist
wirklich häufig nur ein bein dazwischen
haben haben wir in der mitte als zentral
offensiven mittelfeldspieler thomas
müller ist eigentlich mittelstürmer ich
habe die position von dem geänderten der
karte machten auf zentral offensiven
mittelfeld und der geht auch aber jetzt
kommen wir zum sturm leute die position
sicher die meisten interessieren wird da
haben wir rechts vorne zwei stürmer
rechts vorne haben wir timo werner von
rb leipzig richtiges erste tiefer 18 bis
von extrem vielen eingesetzt einfach
weil der ultra schnelles und dann kommen
wir zur zwei beschluss spitzenleute und
das ist der spieler der mir persönlich
am meisten am herzen liegt war auch der
teuerste aus dem ganzen team perego
bamiyan von borussia dortmund ist der
schnellste spieler aus dem gesamten
spielen fifa 18 gibt es keinen spieler
der schneller ist er geht einfach nur ab
das ist wirklich eine maschine und damit
steht auch meine stadt öffentlich gegen
luca antreten werde
jetzt will ich mal sehen was du dagegen
muss man fertig